suppose my car suppose your bad car
right we'll go with that $50,000 map and
you know you're only going to use this
car for five years it's like a company
car or you plan to upgrade or something
okay that leads over those five years
you eventually want to get down to zero
value right you want to have lost all
the values so you get the maximum
benefit for your tax purposes
okay so what I want to do is say well
how my work out how much depreciation
I'm losing every year or what would be
my value attitudes so I want you to draw
for me a little set of axes this has to
be small think back to when we were
looking at linear relationships this is
a linear relationship you can see it's
even in the name telling you it's going
to the menu it says straight line
what would a graph all of this
depreciation look like of the value over
time so I'm gonna label this restrictor
has now
as the name suggests straight line
method of depreciation okay you're gonna
start up here at $50,000 right that's
the value of the cost and after some
number of years you want it to go in a
straight line down to zero so for
instance you might say off to five years
so you can see if I put in a few extra
little markings on my access here right
I've said five years so let's go one two
things that yeah if you say okay one
every year how much am I losing and the
answer is fifty thousand dollars over
five years it's $10,000 okay so for
instance
don't worry your get so close oh you can
see if I said okay what is it off to one
year you can see there's my forty
thousand right
what is it off the to use you can see
there's my thing thousand and you can
keep going down okay
now this picture tells you why this is
colleges and it gives you a great image
of why what is happening but I don't
always want to have to draw a picture
right a lot of this is very predictable
so that's why there is a formula okay so
have a look at this for you with me you
might want to write it down for this one
s equals V naught minus D times and with
another color you can see they've
actually described for you everything
now I'm going to go with their
definition of explain summer wet so
firstly s they have to find s the reason
why they choose the word s is salvage
extensive salvage value salvage there
are a couple of other names for this by
the way which I want you to be able to
recognize I in addition to salary value
they will sometimes call that look value
I'll explain that in a second and the
other thing they sometimes for is
written down now both of these two are
the words phrases rather Book value and
written down though both of these come
from the accounting world right so
you're a company you bought a whole
bunch of cars in your books how much is
that Carly's back to three years old how
much is that the actually work right so
in your books there's a number written
across each one of the cars you purchase
and that's the book value because it's
out there write it down and at some
point does anyone know what happens when
you get rid of something you say it's
worthless
you never write it down you write it if
you have a car and computer away so I
don't say all you wrote off a car right
which is another way to say it's not
worth anything anymore
right so you write it down write down
reduce and reduce it eventually you just
agree it's not on the books anymore you
made it off the books okay so that's the
salvage value that's this art what am i
worth at this current point in time and
there were the rest of these things so
the color these stands for or V naught
rather stands for initial value so why
do you think I mean the V is obviously
providing why do you think they have a
water in here what's that about
zero is kind of like the time it's like
after zero years or zero days or
whatever
good times plus you just bought it brand
new that's the initial that at least
these last two bits I'll talk about in
first and it's pretty standard if we
know like the arms the compound interest
formula and the simple interest formula
they all have ended up what is in refer
to and it's how long you've been doing
this and that's generally years so I'll
say number of and it's usually years
like I said but they say tie periods
yep yep so but you never need to put it
B nor like you can just you don't need
to put that into a calculator as algebra
you just put in the number that it's
actually equivalent to so yeah I don't
think there is not easily lastly lastly
you can see these things for the amount
of apprec-- depreciation other per
period remember we said in this case
that was ten thousand dollars every
single time so this is the depreciation
the lost value so you can see how it
would apply in this particular example
what would our formula for depreciation
be for some number of years you would
say in this case s is equal to let's
have in order for this round for this
part
it's 50,000 that was the initial value
right 50,000 takeaway how much to me so
is depreciation the depreciating every
unit on this particular rap is simple a
graph that I've drawn it's just 10 M
right so I'm gonna write 10,000 there
that's D times n of mini use your life
so in for instance you can see here by
where N equals 5 and it was fine
nearly 50,000 take away 10,000 times 5
which is 50,000 segue 50,000 it's 0
after 5 years
so money after 3 years you can work it
out 50,000 take away a thousand 17,000
so this just tells you where where am i
along the graph what are each of these